we are asked which table has a constant
of proportionality between y and x of
0.6 pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right so just as a reminder the
constant of proportionality between y
and x one way to think about it is that
y is equal to some constant times x
y is proportional to x and this constant
right over here is our constant of
proportionality so if that's going to be
0.6 so in our tables or in the table
that has a constant of proportionality
of 0.6 y should be equal to 0.6 times x
for every xy pair so let's look at these
choices
so is seven zero point six times four
well no seven is larger that than four
zero point six times four would actually
be two point four so this one is not
going to be is definitely not going to
have a constant of proportionality of
0.6 in fact this table this isn't even a
proportional relationship where for this
first one i would have to multiply by
seven-fourths and then here i'm going to
be multiplying by ten-sixths which is
equivalent to
and here i'm multiplying by 13 over
eight so i'm not multiplying by the same
constant every time so this isn't this
isn't even a proportional relationship
now let's look at choice b
well to go from 4 to 2.4 that is you
would multiply by 0.6
but that's not enough for us to say that
this is truly a proportional
relationship it would have to be 0.6 in
every scenario so let's see 9 times 0.6
yeah that is 5.4 9 times 6 is 54 but now
this is 9 times 6 tenths it's 54 divided
by 10 which is 5.4
and let's see 14 times 6 is 84 so 14
times 6 tenths would indeed be 8.4
so this looks like our choice and we can
verify that this would not be the case
let's see three
to get to two we would be multiplying by
two-thirds
and then here once again we're
multiplying by two-thirds and then here
once again we're multiplying by
two-thirds
so this is actually describing a
proportional relationship but our
constant of proportionality here is
two-thirds which if you try to express
it as a decimal would be 0.6 repeating
two-thirds is equal to 0.6
repeating and so
it is proportional but does not have
this constant of proportionality so we
like our choice b